[Musik]
tatort deutschland die treibenden von
bild
aber ich möchte dass der mörder meiner
tochter
ist mein stärkstes anlegen
bekommen man könnte meinen dass sich die
mutter von yasmin stieler verhaspelt hat
wenn sie davon spricht ihrer tochter
komplett zu bekommen nun das ist leider
ganz wörtlich zu verstehen
[Musik]
mein name ist sky dumont und ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen ausgabe vom tatort
deutschland was hat es mit dem wunsch
der mutter auf sich welches verbrechen
führt dazu dass sein opfer nicht
komplett ist der code case den wir heute
an das tageslicht befördern wollen nahm
in der nacht vom 5 zum 6 oktober 1996
seinen unheilvollen anfang wie sich bild
reporterin cornelia missling erinnert
eigentlich auch nie loslassen kann und
auch der staatsanwalt hans-christian
wollte es muss erst einmal tief einatmen
als er von der erfahrenen reporterin mit
den kurzen blonden haaren auf den alten
fall aufmerksam gemacht wird das
natürlich auch bilder die einen
mitnehmen die einen bewegen mein erster
ausbilder hier meine abteilungsleiter
als der in ruhestand gegangen ist 2006
hat er in seiner abschlussrede noch mal
gesagt das einzige was ihnen sozusagen
von seinem berufsleben noch mitnimmt und
wo er immer noch dran zu knabbern hat
ist das der fall spieler nach wie vor
nicht gelöst ist dass es eben nicht
gelungen ist einen tatverdächtigen zu
überführen obwohl er das der mutter im
prinzip versprochen hatte
bild reporterin cornelia missling und
die mutter von yasmin stieler rosmarie
schäfer sitzen wie schon so oft in der
kleinen sitzecke im haus der familie
rosmarie schäfer sieht müde aus um die
augen tiefe dunkle ringe
der kaffee steht unberührt vor
allen dingen ist ganz schlimm
wie auch probleme habe ist er
ja nicht sterben sie wäre jetzt 43 jahre
alt habe ich ausgerechnet ihr heißt
rechte sie hätte jetzt wahrscheinlich
selbst eine familie und selbst kinder
richtig ja und sie enkelkinder ja und
das ist alles das wurde mir vom täter
genommen das wurde mir genommen
cornelia missling es damals als jasmin
verschwindet junge chefreporterin bei
der bild hannover und so von anfang an
mit dem fall vertraut bild titelt damals
schülerin vermisst ermordete jasmin ein
dorf geht zum speicheltest
aber wer war yasmin stieler
[Musik]
jasmin ist ein einzelkind geht auf das
lessing gymnasium im niedersächsischen
uelzen ihre eltern haben sich gerade
scheiden lassen aber sie geht erwachsen
damit um yasmin ist schlank sportlich
ein lebenslustiges mädchen
sie hat einen freund lebt sogar schon in
ihrer eigenen wohnung alles sieht gut
aus mit 18 liegt das ganze leben vor
einem endlich frei sein auf eigenen
beinen stehen hoffnungen und träume
können jetzt wahr werden doch für yasmin
stieler wird all das nicht mehr
passieren denn sie wird ermordet
zerstückelt und in müllsäcken wie unrat
entsorgt bis heute mehr als 25 jahre
nach der tat sind noch immer nicht alle
sterblichen überreste gefunden es fehlen
noch die hände der gymnasiastin und ein
täter läuft noch immer frei herum
was wir sicher wissen ist dass ein
spieler am fünften oktober 1996 gegen 19
uhr genießen einer freundin mitgeteilt
hat dass sie nach braunschweig in die
diskothek atlantis fahren will danach
verliert sich im prinzip die spur
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig
staatsanwalt hans christian wolters hat
einige leitz ordner auf dem riesigen
besprechungstisch ausgebreitet im
auslage noch unzählige akten zum fall
yasmin stieler
auch nach 25 jahren beschäftigen sich
der jungen hafte staatsanwalt und seine
kollegen noch mit dem fall reporterin
cornelia missling beugt sich über die
ordner rückt die brille zurecht beide
werden versuchen die geschehnisse von
damals zu rekonstruieren
uelzen niedersachsen
es ist der fünfte oktober 1996 jasmin
macht sich in ihrer wohnung bereit für
einen partyabend eigentlich will jasmin
zum oktoberfest nach münchen fahren doch
ihrer mutter zuliebe ändert sie ihre
pläne stattdessen muss die 85 kilometer
entfernte disco atlantis in braunschweig
als ziel für diesen samstag abend
ausreichen wie auch die mutter bestätigt
eigentlich wollte ich es nie zusammen
mit einer freundin auf tour gehen doch
die sagt dir kurzfristig ab die 18
jährige macht sich dann selbstbewusst
alleine auf den weg nichts
ungewöhnliches bisher jasmins freundin
ist die letzte die hinweise zu deren
plänen geben kann welche strecke aber
jasmin gefahren welchen zug sie genommen
und wo sie ausgestiegen ist ist nicht
eindeutig belegt cornelia missling
schaut für den akten auf eine schwarz
weiß kopierte karte des großraums
hannover uelzen braunschweig mit
eingezeichneten straßen und bahnstrecken
liegt vor ihr
[Musik]
dort soll sie andere nach dem weg zur
diskothek atlantis gefragt haben ist sie
vor oder nach dem discobesuch auf ihren
mörder gestoßen ist sie ihm freiwillig
gefolgt
irgendwann in der nacht vom fünften auf
den 60
1996 verschwindet jasmin irgendwo rund
um braunschweig
war yasmin stieler ein zufallsopfer oder
hatte ihr mörder sie im visier steckt
hinter dieser grausamen tat vielleicht
sogar ein serientäter für jasmins mutter
zählt nur endlich ihre tochter komplett
beerdigen zu können und dass der mörder
gefasst wird
[Musik]
sonntag der 6 oktober 1996 der tag nach
jasmins verschwinden mutter rosmarie
schäfer macht sich sorgen sonst ruft
jasmin eigentlich immer an manchmal
möchte sich von ihr mit dem auto
abgeholt werden doch diesmal bleibt ein
anruf aus
[Musik]
irgendetwas stimmt nicht alle sachen die
es mir in sonst zum verreisen braucht
sind noch in ihrer wohnung
rosmarie schäfer alarmiert die polizei
bei der suche nach der 18-jährigen
begreifen die ermittler die den ersten
tagen eine besondere maßnahme
[Musik]
für einen besuch in der disco atlantis
kleidet sich eine junge polizeibeamtin
wie die 18 jährige am abend ihres
verschwindens
sie fragt partygäste nach jasmin aber
niemand kann genaue auskunft geben
vermutlich ist jasmin i in der disco
angekommen die polizei tappt im dunkeln
an dieser stelle hinter mir findet ein
spaziergänger neun tage nach dem
verschwinden von jasmin einem blauen
müllsack und in diesem müllsack sind die
sterblichen überreste des mädchens ihr
torso ortsbegehung neben der bahnstrecke
die am ort vechelde unweit von
braunschweig vorbeiführt gibt es einen
kleinen wirtschaftsweg bild reporterin
cornelia misslingen bleibt vor einem
haufen laub und gestrüpp stehen ihr
graut es bei dem gedanken wie der
passant auf den blutverschmierten sack
gestoßen sein muss schon ahnend dass er
einen schrecklichen fund gemacht hat 14
kilometer von der disco entfernt in der
jasmin feiern gehen wollte
die ermittler der staatsanwaltschaft
finden heraus yasmin stieler wurde
erdrosselt wo und wie genau wissen sie
nicht um sich der leiche der 18-jährigen
zu entledigen greift der täter zu
abscheulichen mitteln das heißt der
täter hat jasmin getötet und
anschließend dann die leiche vermutlich
um sie besser beseitigen zu können der
teil
dabei sind die beine vom körper
abgetrennt worden und auch die hände im
bereich des unterarms abgetrennt worden
schließlich ist auch der kopf oberhalb
des hauses abgetrennt worden aufgrund
der spuren an den knochen konnte
zweifelsfrei festgestellt werden dass
die knochen mit einer säge verlegt
worden sind vorher wurde wahrscheinlich
auch ein messer benutzt um die
körperteile vom körper zu trennen
hinweise auf einen kampf oder eine
sexualstraftat finden die ermittler
nicht warum iris - leichnam zerstückelt
wurde ist unklar für ihre heute 66
jährige mutter rosmarie schäfer ist der
fund von jasmins toso der beginn eines
langen albtraums
zurück im büro von staatsanwalt wolters
hier blättert bild reporterin cornelia
missling wieder in den unterlagen und
gleicht sie mit dem kopierten karten
material ab ihr finger tippt auf eine
gruppe kleinerer sehen bei hannover etwa
elf tage nach dem verschwinden von
yasmin stieler wurden in den reglern
teilchen an einem fkk-strand von
spaziergängern ein menschliches bein
gefunden was dort im wasser schwamm bei
der nachsuche konnte dann am nächsten
tag ein weiteres bein gefunden werden
die rechtsmedizinische untersuchung hat
dann ergeben dass es sich um die beine
von yasmin stieler handelt was weiterhin
fehlt sind der kopf und die hände die
bild reporterin begibt sich an den
nächsten fundort ein wald zwischen
hannover und braunschweig ein beliebtes
ausflugsziel in der region friedvolle
lichte baumbestände perfekt für das
wandern und touren mit dem rad
auf knapp 60 kilometern entlang der b 65
zwischen hannover und braunschweig
findet man die leichenteile der
18-jährigen seit 1996 muss rosmarie
schäfer ihre tochter nun schon drei mal
beerdigen
die schweren seelischen wunden können so
die hallen
die staatsanwaltschaft will druck
aufbauen und setzt 50.000 mark belohnung
also rund 25.000 euro aus für
sachdienliche hinweise zur ergreifung
des mörders doch weder dies noch eine
der ersten massen gentests deutschlands
liefern neue spuren zum täter bis heute
sucht die polizei auch nach jasmins
bekleidung der torso war nackt
wo sind die auffällige kuhfell bluse
abgeblieben ihr schwarzer rucksack die
schlüssel und ihr schmuck mysteriös das
fehlende hände die ermittler sind ratlos
und versuchen es erneut mit
unkonventionellen mitteln
september 1997 rund ein jahr nach jasmin
tod gehen sie in die offensive
die polizei hängt an der bahnstrecke
zwischen uelzen hannover und
braunschweig riesige werbeplakate auf
sie sprechen den mörder direkt an der
torso in vechelde der kopf im
hämelerwald die beine in hannover die
hände können sie damit leben
die aktion endet ergebnislos yasmin
stieler wird zum cold case
es ist ruhig in dem fall aber wenige
jahre später gibt es endlich eine spur
ein mutmaßlicher serientäter rückt ins
visier der ermittler auch ein lkw fahrer
aus vechelde gerät in verdacht könnte
eine der beiden der mörder von jasmin
seien die akten auf dem schreibtisch vor
cornelia zeichnen die weiteren
ermittlungen nach 1999 drei jahre nach
dem mord an yasmin stieler drängte sich
ja dann plötzlich der verdacht auch sie
können einem serienmörder in die hände
gefallen sein weil in celle an
schlachter verhaftet wurde nachdem er
eine frau getötet und zerstückelt hatte
auf ähnliche art und weise wie jasmin zu
tode kam auch er hat in die leichenteile
versenkt hat sich dann allerdings
herausgestellt dass dieser beschuldigte
für unsere tat nicht in betracht kamen
ein rückschlag aber 2008 kommt wieder
bewegung in die suche nach dem täter ein
mann der bereits 1999 ins visier der
ermittler geriet gilt als dringend
tatverdächtig
der besagte lkw fahrer aus vechelde sein
arbeitgeber meldet den zur tatzeit
31-jährigen ein damals recht charmant
wirken der lockenkopf der fahrer soll
seinen fahrtenschreiber manipuliert
haben und zwar genau in der nacht in der
jasmin verschwand
dieser tatverdächtige ist am tag nach
jasmins verschwinden in auffälliger
weise von braunschweig nach duisburg
gefahren diese vater hat länger gedauert
als sie eigentlich dauern musste er hat
mehr kilometer
gebraucht als die fahrtstrecke
eigentlich beträgt und er ist dort
verdreckt erschienen was allen damals
schon komisch vorkam all das ließe sich
problemlos damit in einklang bringen
dass er auf dem weg nach duisburg auch
noch die leiche entsorgt hat im frühjahr
2008 finden ermittler einen spaten am
arbeitsplatz eines tatverdächtigen hier
in der nähe des verladebahnhofs an dem
spaten sichern die ermittler ehrt
anhaftung wie sie auch am fundort des
torsos am bahndamm gefunden wurden
jetzt geht alles ganz schnell die
fahnder sammeln genügend indizien um den
mann anzuklagen im herbst 2008 kommt der
lkw-fahrer heiko von k in
untersuchungshaft
ein halbes jahr später soll der prozess
beginnen
rosmarie schäfer ist wie elektrisiert wo
trifft endlich gerechtigkeit zu erfahren
und ihre tochter in frieden ruhen zu
lassen
die täter haben es gab ja eine reihe
sehr gravierender indizien gegen ihn ein
beispiel für dieses auffällige
ausgefeilten war dass er gegenüber der
polizei gesagt hat wenn sie mir die tat
beweisen können gebe ich sie auch zu das
ist so eine äußerung die hört man von
unschuldigen normalerweise nicht das ist
richtig und
leider hat es den richter am
oberlandesgericht
nicht gereicht die entscheidung des
oberlandesgerichts war für uns natürlich
ein herber rückschlag
es ist 12 jahre ermittelt worden durch
die polizei durch die staatsanwaltschaft
wir hatten das gefühl dass wir den
richtigen tatverdächtigen haben wir
haben auch gedacht dass wir ihn
überführen können trotz des
widersprüchlichen verhaltens des
tatverdächtigen familienvater
lassen die indizien zu viel raum für
mögliche andere tatverdächtige die
anklage wird abgewiesen
weggezogen ein schlag ins gesicht der
mutter selbst wenn man jetzt noch
beweise fände wäre ein neues verfahren
nicht sicher denn gegen den angeklagten
wird damals nur wegen totschlags
ermittelt wenn wir nur einen totschlag
nachweisen könnten wäre eine
gerichtliche aufarbeitung nicht mehr
möglich wir könnten allerdings einen
mord weiterverfolgen mord verjährt nie
dafür ist aber erforderlich dass wir
bestimmte mord merkmale haben wie
mordlust befriedigung des
geschlechtstriebs solche dinge auch
jetzt 25 jahre nach dem verbrechen
geben mutter rosemarie schäfer und die
staatsanwaltschaft die hoffnung nicht
auf oder auch die bild-redaktion bleibt
an dem fall dran
ist es noch möglich diesen fall zu lösen
bitte beachtet gleich den aufruf am ende
dieses podcasts bis zum nächsten mal sky
dumont ach ja die mutter von jasmin hat
eine nachricht an den täter als dieser
hier zuhört
ich gebe keine ruhe man sieht sich
für hinweise die zur rechtskräftigen
verurteilung des täters führen gibt es
eine belohnung von 70.000 euro die
polizei fragt wer hat yasmin stieler
nach dem 5 oktober 1996 19 uhr noch
gesehen
insbesondere im raum braunschweig
vielleicht auch im umfeld der diskothek
atlantis wer kann angaben dazu machen wo
die kleidungsstücke jasmin stil
ausgeblieben sind insbesondere die
auffällige kuhfell bluse
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus den wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone terbrack
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
lutz neumann
redaktion bild cornelia misslingen und
stefan netzeband